just a quick heads-up I'm not going to
show any pictures of tissue damage
caused by black salve because it's
pretty gross however if you want you can
go into Google Images and look for
yourself but don't say I didn't warn you
so what exactly is black salve black
salve is a topical anti tumour cream
that's used to physically remove tumors
and is usually done without any
professional medical supervision or
approval here's how it works one day you
find a growth on your body you go to the
doctor and he tells you it's cancerous
instead of seeking treatment from the
person who diagnosed the cancer in the
first place
you rub blacks ad on the tumor and leave
it there for a few minutes up to several
hours within a few weeks to a month the
tumor dies falls off and you're
cancer-free this sounds too good to be
true which of course it is because this
isn't anti tumor cream it's anti skin
cream the two active ingredients in
black salve that give it the ability to
kill off tissue are a zinc chloride a
caustic salt and sanguinarine a toxic
alkaloid extracted from the sanguine
arena and can denise's plant or the
blood root flower the combination of
these two ingredients are incredibly
lethal to living tissue zinc chloride
being a caustic salt similar to ly
causes burns to your skin and is advised
to be removed immediately upon contact
the sanguinary
toxin kills tissue by blocking sodium
potassium pumps preventing the flow of
sodium and potassium ions across the
cell membrane as a result cells can't
perform regular functions causing them
to die now you may be thinking well why
is this a problem if it's doing all this
to a tumor isn't it good that it's
killing off the cancerous growth yes if
plaques add discriminately killed off a
tumor by itself then this would be a
medical breakthrough however since it's
just a mixture of caustic salt and cell
toxins it just destroys tissue as long
as it's applied the idea is to apply the
black salve the right amount of time so
that it just kills the tumor then you
remove the SAP before it damages healthy
tissue
well I'm here to tell you that that's
stupid and won't work because the tumor
is being killed off by unregulated
tissue destruction which turns out is a
bad thing because you can't control it
and more importantly it causes necrosis
necrosis is a process in which an
abnormally large number of cells die off
an unregulated in catastrophic manner
either by presence of a toxin like a
snakebite or severe injury this is
highly destructive because the cells
upon catastrophic death release enzymes
that aren't supposed to be released in
large quantities outside the cell
these released enzymes break down the
cell membrane of neighboring cells
causing these cells to release their
enzymes resulting in a domino effect
additionally this damage causes cells in
the vicinity to become stressed and
release signaling proteins this recruits
immune cells causing further
inflammation and injury this destructive
pathway is what causes the severe tissue
damage associated with black sev in
summary the reason why black salve kills
tumors is because it's formulated to
kill any living tissue it comes in
contact with it's not an anti tumor
treatment it's a pro necrotic agent
using black salve is no different than
removing a tumor with hydrochloric acid
and sandpaper on the stupid scale I'm
reading blacks AB at a seven out of ten
because though people who have cancer
may get incredibly desperate you should
never try to treat it yourself ever on
the harmful scale blacks AB is without a
doubt a ten out of ten
[Music]